[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 loisirs sur
tv 78 chaque jeudi l'essentiel des
informations pour passer un bon week end
dans le département voici le sommaire de
cette semaine le 21 septembre ce sera le
world clean up des îles opérations et
mondial la france y participe depuis
l'an dernier cette année dans les
yvelines des dizaines de villes sont
mobilisés dont montigny le bretonneux
l'organisatrice locale est en plateau
les journées européennes du patrimoine
vont débuter tour d'horizon du programme
dans le département et il y en a pour
tous les goûts et puis l'agenda complet
bien sûr de vos sorties avec du sport
notamment tennis et natation pour
débuter j'accueille sur ce plateau and
heroes bas bienvenue en plateau merci
nous avoir rejoints vous êtes la
présidente de je respecte ma ville sur
montigny le bretonneux et vous allez
organiser cette journée de nettoyage de
la planète sur la commune de montigny le
bretonneux c'est déjà une tâche bien
lourde cela va se dérouler dans
l'ensemble des quartiers de la commune
comment ça va s'organiser
concrètement cette opération du 21
septembre pendant les huit quartiers
effectivement c'est la deuxième fois que
nous le faisons aussi le contenu on a
commencé l'année dernière avec le
quartier des prés on s'est bien amusé et
cette année on a décidé de le faire dans
les huit quartiers de la ville
conviviale finalement forcément même si
on va reparler 20 cl
et puis un gamma est toujours alarmants
malheureusement ce qu'il faut il faut
souligner quand même ces incivilités là
et ces opérations de nettoyage vous les
avez déjà débuté en cours de semaine
avec les plus jeunes au collège
giacometti donc à montigny le bretonneux
nous vous avons suivi et reportages
l'activité de ce mercredi après midi au
collège giacometti est un peu
particulière après avoir formé les trois
équipes les 25 volontaires s'équipent
des gants des pinces et des sacs
recyclables bien entendu l'association
je respecte ma ville les a conviés à une
séance de ramassage de déchets
l'histoire de la planète mais n'en
consacre hommes conservent beaucoup les
écoliers ils sont engagés par les
écouler sur tous les jeunes aussi ils
sont engagés dans la préservation de
l'environnement
et aujourd'hui c'était sur la base du
volontariat et ils sont tous venus parce
qu'il avait envie de faire du bien à la
planète et c'est formidable bout de
papier bâtons de sucettes et emballage
de bonbons constituent l'essentiel de la
récolte dans la cour de récréation des
jeunes qui se montre sensible aux causes
environnementales tout ce qui est
écologie c'est plutôt important or avec
tout ce qui est réchauffement climatique
et tout il faut qu'on commence à se
bouger et c'est alors même s'il faut
commencer par un petit bout autant
commencer par là ensuite on va continuer
en fumier retrouver les revenir devant
dernier passage devant l'établissement
les bâtons de sucettes se transforme en
bégaud de cigarettes avant un quizz pour
déterminer la longévité des déchets
avant leur dégradation suivie d'une
pause réconfort faut aider la planète
parce que si on fait pas maintenant les
choses bande qui le fera après sur la
base du volontariat
nous sommes passés avec trois élèves de
5e qui ont initié le projet dans les
classes nous avons pris cinq minutes pas
plus pour expliquer ce que c'était que
le wac inapte à dire aux élèves que nous
pouvions le faire à échelle locale et
cinq minutes ont suffi justement pour
recueillir 26 à 30 candidatures et sur
ses presque 30 candidatures résidents
ont peu près de 25
ce jour les ramasseurs du jour vous
invitent à les rejoindre samedi pour
cette journée internationale du
ramassage de déchets l'opération s'est
déroulée avec les plus jeunes est ce que
le message passe bien auprès de ces
jeunes justement très bien beaucoup et
surtout cette école l'aller le collège à
committee c'est une école qui est
vraiment engagée dans l'éco citoyenneté
ils font beaucoup d'opérations
responsable toute l'année et c'est avec
plaisir qu'ils nous ont accueillis
mercredi dernier le world cleanup des a
été lancée il ya bientôt une dizaine
d'années certains pays dont la lettonie
notamment ça fait seulement deux ans en
france on pourrait se dire aussi toutes
ces incivilités aurait aurait pu être
évité beaucoup plus tôt là aujourd'hui
dix ans après le lancement à travers
l'europe deux ans après le lancement en
france vous fait toujours le même
constat
oui mais ses dix ans d'existence de la
fondation qui a créé edouard nabe
d'aimer ces deux années seulement existe
sur les ménages
et est-ce qu'il ya une amélioration ne
serait-ce que ce que vous avez pu
réaliser avec le collège giacometti il
ya une sensibilisation la
sensibilisation fonctionne beaucoup oui
ils te font attention aux déchets qu'ils
jettent ils passent le message à leurs
parents c'est aussi la levée et il ya
beaucoup plus conscience que nous nous
en avions trente ans il était plus jeune
est-ce que tout au long de l'année vous
mener d'autres opérations de ce type
bien sûr notre association a pour but de
sensibiliser au respect du cadre de vie
donc nos terres investigations c'est les
fêtes de quartier des fêtes d'école et
fait entreprises mais mais maintenant on
va en maison de retraite
on fait beaucoup d'action justement pour
ont déjà créé du lien entre les gens et
puis évangéliser pour que la planète est
ce au profit de notre ville surtout dont
je respecte mais qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé vous justement a lancé cette
association se respecte ma ville c'est
parti d'un agacement du constat que les
caddies prenait beaucoup de place dans
les parties communes des immeubles et
donc avec des voisins elle a décidé de
faire une action de faire quelque chose
on a rencontré notre bailleur mais à
l'époque c'était logements franciliens
qui avait mené mille vies qui nous a
aidés dans la première campagne que nous
avons mené dans la résidence et puis
après on s'est dit bon mêlant pour
s'attaquer aux cadis on va peut-être
s'attaquer aux balcons encombré on va
s'attaquer aux dépôts sauvages
on a beaucoup de travail c'est vrai
mais et puis on s'est dit puisque ça
commence à marcher on va peut-être
s'étendre à la ville et puis ça faire
connaître et faire les actions beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus grand et puis cette
action symbolique aussi un puisqu'elle
se déroule partout en même temps dans
l'ensemble des pays
les nettoyons la planète tous ensemble
pendant ce week end il ya les journées
du patrimoine et puis aussi cet autre
opération à travers le monde entier
est ce que justement vous avez fait un
peu d'émulation combien aujourd'hui vous
êtes au sein de votre association vous
avez été dans notre sens et surtout le
bureau quand on a beaucoup de
sympathisants qui s'inscrivent au fur et
à mesure les manifestations donc vous
attendez beaucoup de monde lors de
l'opération et ce week end
on espère on a fait une bonne campagne
david nous a soutenus port et on espère
qu'il y aura beaucoup de monde
rendez vous au coeur de vos quartiers à
montigny le bretonneux et puis si vous
n'êtes pas dans cette commune à travers
les yvelines de nombreuses villes
participent le programme complet sur un
site internet world clean up des et vous
aurez toutes les informations merci à
vous voir cette rumeur le 7-8 loisirs
qui se poursuit avec un point sur les
journées du patrimoine de très nombreux
rendez vous aux quatre coins du
département notamment à rambouillet tout
d'abord avec au coeur de l'hippodrome
une exposition du scénographe jean
baptiste même manessier pardon qui
travaille depuis 1962 pour le théâtre
les marionnettes le cinéma le ballet
l'opéra il conçoit des maquettes il
donnera aussi des conférences elles
quant à odile aucun comédienne et
chanteuse elle comptera des extraits de
spectacles avec son orgue de barbarie
au même moment à poissy c'est toute la
ville qui propose des propose des
visites le musée du jouet le prix or et
saint louis à la villa savoye la
collégiale notre-dame programme très
riche avec là aussi la conférence et
spectacles et puis entre possibilité de
sortie une visite des salons de la
préfecture et de l'hôtel du département
le dimanche à un bâtiment construit sur
l'ancien chenil du roi inauguré en 1867
et qui a été le cadre de plusieurs à
événement politique de première
importance
l'ancien la ville nouvelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ne manque pas
non plus d'arguments pour vous séduire
vélodrome à montigny le bretonneux
observatoire à guyancourt port royal des
champs aussi à magny les hameaux
le château de la verrière encore de
plaisir vous propose des visites
commentées et puis bien sûr rendez vous
aussi à la commanderie d'elancourt le
nouveau lieu centralisateur de la
culture pour l'agglomération saint
quentin en yvelines c'est une réussite
et c'est une des sites dans tous les
domaines et donc en particulier aussi
dans la culture justement on va avec la
nouvelle je peux pas appeler ça la
nouvelle culture mais la culture adaptés
au mode de vie des habitants
on est plus il n'ya pas la danse d'un
côté puis la danse classique campagne
c'est en fait avec les nouvelles
méthodes et puis en fait vous voyez que
le numérique que ça ne se soit produit
partout et c'est ça qu'on veut
développer
toujours dans le cadre des journées du
patrimoine l'inria ouvre aussi ses
portes à rocquencourt l'institut
national de recherche en sciences du
numérique où 200 personnes travaillent
aujourd'hui un site créé en 1952 par les
troupes alliées nous avons vraiment la
chance sur ce domaine historique d'avoir
des vestiges de l'après-guerre qui
préfigurait ce qu'allait finalement
devenir le site par la suite avec un
haut lieu de l'histoire de
l'informatique et une aria aujourd'hui
[Musique]
en sport à présent rendez vous au centre
aquatique du lac à montigny le
bretonneux pour des animations pour la
famille avec des défis des structures
gonflables entrées payantes au tarif
habituel elle ce sera samedi 21
septembre et puis est du tennis
également avec le tournoi international
futur une douzaine de nationalités
différentes des joueurs classés entre
les trois centièmes les 500e première
place mondiale ce tournoi qui existe
depuis 1993 à plaisir c'est le plus gros
tournoi d'ile-de-france après roland
garros et bercy il a vu passer de grands
noms jo wilfried tsonga michaël llodra
l'entrée est gratuite deux plaisirs oies
se sont même qualifiés dans le tableau
final la grande finale ce sera dimanche
à partir de 15 heures c'est un tournoi
qui permet à tous les chemins
professionnels à tous les espoirs
les jeunes espoirs qu'ils soient
français ou étrangers
évidemment de d'avoir des points atp
voir des politesses maintenant et
ensuite d'aller dans des tournois plus
importants comme les challengers ou bien
les grands chelems et pourquoi pas
[Musique]
quittons les yvelines à présent avec nos
confrères de via grand paris hicham
chaîne régionale diffusée sur la tnt qui
vous propose de découvrir aujourd'hui
l exposition de yann arthus bertrand à
la défense yann arthus-bertrand expose
son patrimoine photographique la grande
arche de la défense accueille sa toute
première rétrospective legacy revient
sur cinquante ans de travail de ses
premières prises de vue au kenya jusqu
aux portraits de français qu'il continue
encore aujourd'hui
au total 281 clichés et cinq films
remplissent espace de 1200 m² avec cet
héritage
yann arthus-bertrand encourage désormais
la nouvelle génération à s'engager
pleinement dans un métier qu'il vit
comme un rêve
la terre est une oeuvre d'art je suis
vraiment que le témoin de tout ça n'est
pas un artiste chaque fois qu'on appuie
sur le bouton
j'ai beaucoup de chance j'ai un métier
de rêve je pense que tous les jeunes qui
viennent me voir qu'ils ont envie de le
faire je le redis tous essayé
n'abandonnez pas fait la difficile et
compliqué mais si vous y arrivez vous
serez l'homme le plus heureux du monde
d'être photographe
aujourd'hui c'est d'aller dans le milieu
envie de faire c'est un système la mode
si tu aimes tu vois les animaux thème le
sport tu peut pénétrer ce milieu et
c'est une chance formidable il faut pas
être très malin pour être photographe
la preuve regarde regarde moi artiste
engagé yann arthus-bertrand livre un
bilan contrasté avec les gars si ils
expriment une pensée partagés entre
inquiétude pour la planète et
amélioration des conditions de vie
humaine tient peu l'héritage que ma
génération laisse aux jeunes il ya du
bon et du mauvais donc une réflexion sur
où va le monde une autre génération a
emmené le monde quand je suis né un t2
milliards voire 2 7 milliards 700
millions le monde va beaucoup mieux on
vit beaucoup plus vieux il ya moins de
mortalité infantile il ya plus de
démocratie ya moins de gens qui ont faim
et en même temps on s'est beaucoup
occupé de l'homme des basses et de la
nature qui nous entoure et du climat
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui dans un monde
compliqué difficile avec un changement
climatique majeur qui est en train
d'arriver qu'on n'arrive pas à arrêter
avec une perte de la biodiversité et
c'est une réflexion sur la beauté du
monde
legacy est exposée jusqu'au 1er décembre
avant que certains clichés ne soient
mises en vente au profit de sa fondation
goodplanet
c'est la fin du set 8 le loisir émission
à retrouver dès à présent replay sur
notre site internet sur l'application
mobile rendez vous jeudi prochain 18h30
sur tv soixante dix huit pour de
nouvelles idées sorties
[Musique]